skin is really tiny man oh it's gonna
grab you back why you fell for that
let's see the cat named kitty nickel
nickel Shan Mei back no not nickel back
the best band ever
Nick your son is that it yeah sure
oh now I can move all right great let's
say some of the new men the DD Matt
that's Lee Jay what is this oh it's
mirrored isn't it why don't you say this
alright so we have to go to the riot
instead of left now I mean yeah no you
have to go right they didn't buy it I
don't know how do you take those boxes
he [ __ ] don't know on this oh wow see
you later oh god you have a did you die
cry no wait strawberry scrub this is
yeah are you batch yeah feelings have
never been so hurt no don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
did I hit me where's the DJ it I'm the
DJ at this party bare girl whatever
which I said oh those those boxes chichi
[ __ ] alright [ __ ] you man mmm I said
I'm dead I'm so that wait up guys wait
up guys come on Ronnie batch
I'm still with you now I'm dead I think
I'm dead I'm dead kitty cat is it
amazing oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] card there
you go
nice ones hi thank you you're welcome
oh I'm always set it to help yourself
conscience and stuff yeah yes because
anyone need a win
oh all right we lose I just wanted you
to lose that's the bet there are there's
a DD guy I don't know if you son but he
was an SI Sheamus hehe was there no I
wouldn't lie to you god damn that was a
great [ __ ] that was a great to hook
man Jesus thank you good job I did it
again wrong way [ __ ] sorry
it happens all right you're going down
to funky town and that's not a great
time for you crying it's a good song
it's a bad part of town it's a bad bad
don't you dare hook me though son of a
bee sting you [ __ ] ass licking
[ __ ] sorry I'm late average all
over you right now how the [ __ ] you get
all the UPS man you get all the UPS drop
boxes on your [ __ ] don't [ __ ] a me
it's going on not gonna lose the [ __ ]
kitty you [ __ ] neck of [ __ ] nickel
nickel back wins again nickel back and
going nickel my back if you know what
I'm saying
I don't know what your [ __ ] you're
saying I don't I don't want to swear too
much I'm sorry mom yeah mom bill this
name he's bad influence damn right now
now can't get up there's a disco balls
do anything for [ __ ] sake now for
[ __ ] sake Oh for [ __ ] sake you okay
yeah I'm coming for ya yeah that's right
bye Oh for [ __ ] sake
ah [ __ ] so many banks if oh god you you
[ __ ] okay
this bad okay fine yes we should i
there's gonna be a thing coming up here
good how does that make you feel the
same as I did with a second ago
everybody quiet rock-hard mood what is
that about that it's about winning and
not being I guess yes sir what is that I
was you know I was the host
he wants a boxes take them there freeze
[ __ ] suck those boxes so tasty I know
you like it oh sure why would I I [ __ ]
later oh yeah yeah later
yeah later cry later yeah I'll see you
later
you [ __ ] yeah come on back here oh my
god ah boxes every [ __ ] time I got a
box man oh that gave me elf the speed of
justice Ultra speed of justice yep
oh-oh-oh-oh
wants to go oh taunt taunt I Tod oh god
what a finite time why did I God why did
I yeah oh god don't you sat on me please
please son
oh god oh oh yeah you said use it all
you want come back here yeah yeah you a
small dick sort of a shame
possessed a ship and all items are
rockets and you can get three of them
Wow
great no grapple okay thank God that's
that's all I right now mmm-hmm right kid
II can't keep up with those dodges what
kid II can't walk through oh yeah this
is the spikes part this [ __ ]
apartment what I what what I used to get
randomly by rocket it's a bullish
crapper here's three of them oh yeah
forgot drop-kicked you I don't know how
the hell we cut up with him there
oh gosh spikes Jesus Wow yeah those are
spikes Jesus come down with the [ __ ]
Rockets mate goddamn it mate I love your
guys right not for [ __ ] sake oh [ __ ] see
one that nobody oh thank god that's
bullcrap rockets from before the [ __ ] is
that about
they were my rackets I know but yeah
great last night mr. moose you didn't
even take the turbo diva now saying
listen I even know you guys place a lot
more than I know we don't rain every
Friday every Friday I go alike I want to
walk rides doing speedrunners don't
genetic right
don't an a everyone has one point this
is bad happy [ __ ] sake stop with it
let me at least try and run all right
yeah they keep losing which one is me
every time you're the Meuse yeah oh my
god I shoot rockets alright go
dang it oh it kicked me oh yes
not for [ __ ] sake
take the wrong turn didn't it yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's how we do it in the pudding
my damn right Johnny what's up so angry
yeah every time sorry to God I could
have won
anyone could have won this race that's
pretty amazing never have the Amazing
Race
it is arrays oh don't do don't do that
what are you guys sister one with your
Rockets I don't really know how it
sounds I'm crying you have to win by
taunting it's a right trigger good
content oh you can see one listen
respect for you crying listen I've
gotten married every grapple is an
option that would be horrible eat my
kitty dirt
I love kitty get a girls I don't love no
wait now I'm confused
[ __ ] them fairies I am 9 yes oh that's
not the way yeah that's not the rocket
dunya man I don't know what's your
problem with these man I'm drunk
oh god I can go here there's a coffin
this is [ __ ] up
and it's games dark man I'm so sad in
your ass
hmm don't do it it's uh there's bubbles
here but if I can only go up with the
bubbles that's bullcrap err Shan you
don't have a shine I'm a cat John does
have an intro shot you guys should go
left took off for [ __ ] sake
[ __ ] sake wait up you have to hate you
why is that mmm we like what's your
problem and then loose someone give a
[ __ ]
wait wait stop being stunned you little
last white I said it
how dare you I said it I said it and now
you know it's you can't take it back you
regret it it's like toothpaste
once it's out it doesn't go in of what
exactly words Oh for [ __ ] sake thank
you for [ __ ] sake that is bollock
wrapper and you know it
kitty can go suck a dick all right
oh come on I'm not gonna let this come
here you [ __ ] Dutch little
that's even dutch I'm not much do you
have to tell us you don't even talk bro
this right trigger I said it you're a
bull listen it's not right trigger [ __ ]
right bumper ass [ __ ] now jumped off
the top of level and that sucks
I'll love you guys I'm sorry I don't
mean it yeah okay take that in your ass
whoever grapple spirit die or you love
me thank you
what the [ __ ] with what the [ __ ] is that
don't tell him oh yeah there's powers
heading it powers use powers B if you
use the controller uh don't you never
say right yes yeah you nico-chan batch
cool pokemons pokemons pokemons are so
1999 oh that's why do I have to start in
the area who wants it no no I don't want
it can't do yet why I waited to grapple
you and in the grapple that just didn't
work
hey Matt's going nikkor chen boxes if
that even is your real name you carry
son of a [ __ ] thanks [ __ ] cowboy you
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] sake [ __ ] sake it's not
go right it was that's I told you races
I'm sorry
well you know what deal with it Oh for
[ __ ] sake oh I know unless Ken wins
now there's no chance of me winning in
that it doesn't look good because you
can't [ __ ] later can take it that was
you like your moment
that was your rebecca black [ __ ]
Rebecca Black
cry has a grapple yeah I do yeah I like
this odds oh my god cries so tryharding
oh my god Emily oh my god oh my god okay
that's good is really tiny man oh he's
gonna grab you back why you fell for
that
Oh amazing
beyond oh my god
never seen anything hard I'm sorry I'll
shut up what the [ __ ] have you done take
those boxes while you're at it you [ __ ]
shut your [ __ ] mouth all right
Oh God dang it who has those buster I
have a grapple oh good and it's about to
get dirty in this footprint you're not
you guys are not allowed to take the
sweet route of two we're [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] see you later alligator
hate us forgot it in grapple wait why
are you still alive how are you not dead
that's pretty good don't do anything
stupid now don't do anything okay I know
what you want to do you little [ __ ] but
I'm not gonna let it happen alright now
what are you what do you don't try to
touch it you [ __ ] oh my god good
now let's try knock him down but it hit
myself instead and we should do want to
try to get quite updated this is very
interesting yeah yeah before this game
was like [ __ ]
fionna it's not gonna lie yeah you
couldn't even play it yeah the
connectivity was really bad that's
pretty good what is
you run all right yeah great
I guess you always have boosts you know
if you guys need a gimmick to win yeah
that's fine with me
Oh God Jesus Christ this is really fast
come here back here oh no sure oh no
wait go superfast don't beside it on me
don't be sanic ah [ __ ] you're too slow
why did you go damn what was that hey
what is that what's up in the face oh
geez I forgot how [ __ ] fast you are
it's wait up seriously you're someone
else as a grapple it's like a and B plus
one but if I wanted to go ahead and get
all the boxes while you're at it
I just judge you even though you don't
have to stop you can you can don't add
slide and that takes it away now [ __ ]
did you hear me [ __ ] Jesus that's a
violent group and this gonna be nice and
he doesn't even [ __ ] say thanks
what'd you say
Ida [ __ ] you I'm gonna say it again damn
okay
awful [ __ ] sake oh all right you know
what suck it [ __ ] Komaki [ __ ] yeah where
are you going where are you going
I don't have it anymore what the [ __ ] Oh
what happened to it no no bye no don't
you dare grapple you like Rockets cry
you go so fast you'll end up shooting
yourself up with that though you just
grab with nothing I grapple through the
wall because I'm a [ __ ]
Pro and you guys have bunch of scrubs
don't scrapple me though please ah
appreciate it don't worry I'll just hit
all the boxes instead oh my god you guys
are so bad at this
no wrong way oh my god isn't humiliating
ah not for [ __ ] sake Nick HN I thought
I knew you Ben apparently you were just
out for [ __ ] sake oh come on
oh you don't with the boost you don't
like boosts oh now it's the mind game
I'd be such an Xbox kid holy [ __ ] oh yes
me just go home I am home what do you
think I play this from where do you
think I am right now I'm sorry are you
expecting me to be out right now BD baby